بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول تعالى ولا تجسسوا قد مر بنا
الشطر الاول من الايه الكريمه
وهي قوله سبحانه وتعالى يا ايها الذين
امنوا اجتنبوا كثيرا من الظن ان بعض الظن
اثم اثم هنا اطلق المصدر واريد به اسم
الفاعل يعني المقصود ان بعض الظن اثم يعني
مؤثم
ومكسب للاثم
وهذا للمبالغه في
عظمه هذا الذنب
عند الله سبحانه وتعالى
والاثم كما سبق
في اصل وضع اللغه العربي
لاصل لغه العرب الاثم
وما يثقل الماثوم عن فعل الخير
والاصل في الاثم شرعا انه
الذي من الاثام يعني من الذنوب عند الله
معصيه لله سبحانه وتعالى
ويكسب صاحبه
الهلاك عند الله
ولكن في القران
الاصل اذا وجدنا كلمه اثم فمعناها الذنب
لكن قد يطلق ويراد به المعنى اللغوي
وهذا في مثل قول الله سبحانه وتعالى
يسالونك
ويسالونك عن الخمر والميسر
قل فيهما اثم كبير
هذه الايه اتفق العلماء
على انها انزلت ترغيبا
عن
شرب الخمر وعن الميسر
وان الخمر
وان شرب الخمر لم يحرم بهذه الايه تعلمون
الخمر
تحريمه
او حكمه في الاسلام مر على اربعه مراحل
المرحله الاولى الاباحه
الثانيه
الكراهيه
والثالثه التحريم اوقات الصلاه
والمرحله الاخيره التحريم البات
والمرحله الثانيه
حيث انتقل حكم الخمر شرب الخمر من الاباحه
الى الكراهيه
فبقوله تعالى قل فيهما اثم كبير ومنافع
للناس واثمهما اكبر من نفعهما لو كانت هنا
بمعنى الذنب بمعنى المعصيه لا كان الخمر
حراما بنزول هذه الايه فيهما اثم كبير
خلاص لكن
الصحابه رضي الله عنهم لم يفهموا ذلك
وانما فهموا ان هذا
ترغيب من الله سبحانه وتعالى
عن شرب الخمر
قال سبحانه وتعالى ولا تجسسوا
قلنا التجسس
الاصل في هذه الكلمه
ولا تتجسسوا
ولا تتجسسوا لكن التاء
اسقطت
لتكرار وللتخفيف لان
التاء مكرره ففي لغه العرب يسقطون هذه
الحروف المكرره
فاصبحت ولا تجسسوا يعني لا تتجسسوا
والتجسس
هو من الجسر في اللغه
والجس مثل الحس
حتى الرسم نفس الرسم
ح
اء والجيم المعجمه في الاصل نفس الرسم
والاشتقاق نفسه ويعود الى نفس هذه الحروف
وذلك ان الحس باليد قال العلماء
منهم الفراء ان الحس الفرق بين الحس والجس
تقول
حسسته او جسسته
بنفس المعنى تقريبا لكن يظهر المعنى
والاختلاف
ان الحس لوجود الشيء والجس
لماهيه الشيء
ايش يعني هذا الكلام يعني خلينا نقول
في كيس معلق
وهذا الكيس
لا ارى ما فيه
فادخل وامسكه بيدي هذا اسمه ايش حس يعني
ادركته بحواسي
لكن اذا
تركت الكيس هيك عشان احس شو اللي جواه
بالضبط
تعرف على ماهيه
داخل هذا الكيس فهذا اسم جس
هذا الفرق مهم
لماذا حتى نفهم عن الله سبحانه وتعالى
جاء في قراءه شاذه وهي قراءه عن
التابعين ان بعضهم كان يقرا ولا تحسسوا
ولكن المتواتر في القراءه ولا تجسسوا
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في صحيح مسلم
يقول
لا تحسسوا ولا تجسسوا ولا
يغتب بعضكم بعضا وكونوا عباد الله اخوانا
ولا تدابروا ولا تحاسدوا ولا تباغضوا
احاديث عن ابن عمر وابي هريره معروفه في
الصحيح وفي غيره
فالمعنى يكون
التحسس منهي عنه
والتجسس من هي عنه التجسس ليس له صوره
جائزه
على المؤمن
بان المؤمن محترم عند الله وفي شريعه الله
سبحانه وتعالى
وكان التجسس حصل
التجسس في الحرب مع الكافرين هذا النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم كان يرسل عيونه احيانا
الى من هم ليسوا بمسلمين او من كانوا
متظاهرين بالاسلام وقد يكونون
متربصين للمسلمين فهذا من الحرب
واما تجسس
المؤمن على المؤمن فانه لا يجوز ومحرم
واما التحسس فايضا لا يجوز وهو دون التجسس
وقد ذكر بعض العلماء ان التحسس
وطلب الاخبار عن الاخرين
والتجسس ان يبحث عنها بنفسه
باسلوب خفي
يعني وباسباب خفيه تخفى على المتجسس عليه
وصوره كثيره خاصه في هذا الزمان
لكن التحسس مثل طلب الاخبار
والفضائح عن الناس من الاخرين
ايش سمعتوا في فلان ايش حصل مع فلان وهيك
وهذا كان من فعل الخبثاء المنافقين في عهد
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وذلك
ان المنافقين لما قالوا
في عائشه ام المؤمنين رضي الله عنها ما
قالوا
فان الذي تولى كبر هذا الامر
والذي تولى كبره
يعني كان السبب
الاكبر في هذا
لم يقم عليه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
الحد
صح ولا لا يعني عبد الله بن ابي بن سلول
لم
يقم عليه الحد مع ان هذه الايه فيه انزلت
والذي تولى كبره في سوره النور
لماذا لم يقم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
الحد عليه خلاف بين المواطئين والعلماء
ولكن قد يكون اظهر هذه الاقوال انه لم يقل
ذلك صراحه
يعني ما اتهمها صراحه وقال هي فعلت ما قال
هذا
وانما كان
يتحسس الاخبار في المجامع حتى ينشر عنها
هذا الكلام
فاذا كان بين اولئك الذين يتكلمون يقول
ايش حصل خير ان شاء الله يعني عن عائشه لا
ما سمعت ايش اللي صار عشان غيره يتحدث
بهذا الكلام على مسامع الناس
[Silence]
له عذاب عظيم عند الله واليم
فهذا هو التحسس النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
لما يقول لا تحسسوا هو هذا هو التحسس
هو طلب الاخبار من الاخرين
والسؤال والبحث عن فضائح الناس هذا اسم
تحسس
ولذلك تجد مثلا
ان يعقوب عليه السلام لم يامر اولاده
بالتجسس
قال اذهبوا فتحسسوا من يوسف واخيه يعني
التمسوا وجودهما
استمعوا واسالوا الناس عن اخبارهما لعلك
لعلكم
تجدون تجدونهما
التجسس
يكون طلب الاخبار
والعورات يكون طلب العوره
يعني مثلا الذي كان يطلب
منقبه لغيره يعني هذا فلان يخفي عمله لكنه
مثلا ياتي المسجد
وينظر اليه وهو لا يشعر به وهو يعمل الخير
هذا ليس تجسسا لانه لم يتتبع عوراته تجسس
خاص بالعورات
وهذا التجسس
نهى الله سبحانه وتعالى عنه
ويكون
باسباب خفيه تخفى على
المتجسس عليه
هذه
محرمه في الاسلام تحريما باتا
ويتاكد هذا التحريم من قبل
الولي ومن قبل الحكومات والنبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
يقول انك اذا
ابتغيت الريبه في الناس افسدته وان الوالي
اذا ابتغى الريبه في الناس
افسدهم هذه من روايه معاويه وذكر الصحابه
رضي الله عنهم ان الله نفع معاويه بهذه
الروايه التي سمعها من النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم وهذه مساله يستغرب منها يعني
نحن الان لا يمكن لاحدنا
ان يكون في اي قطر من اقطار الارض الا وثم
حكومه لها
جناح متجسس عليه صعب جدا انه احنا نتصور
الوحده او احنا نتصور الانعزال التام الذي
لا يراك فيه الا الله سبحانه وتعالى ولكن
هكذا كانت حرمه المسلم والمؤمن في عهد
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
من اجل ذلك ياتي السؤال
ويتكرر كثيرا عن بعض ما يقوم به بعض الناس
وسياتي البيان في ذلك ان شاء الله
وقفت على كلام
قديما
في هذا المعنى وجدت طيبا احببت ان اقراه
عليكم يقول صاحب الظلال والتجسس
قد يكون هو الحركه التاليه للظن وقد يكون
حركه ابتدائيه لكفش في العورات والاطلاع
على السوئات
والقران يقاوم هذا العمل الدنيء من
الناحيه الاخلاقيه
لتطهير القلب من مثل هذا الاتجاه اللئيم
لتتبع عورات الاخرين وكشف سواتهم
وتمشيا مع اهدافه في نظافه الاخلاق
والقلوب
ولكن الامر ابعد من هذا اثرا
فهو مبدا من مبادئ الاسلام الرئيسيه في
نظامه الاجتماعي
وفي اجراءاته التشريعيه والتنفيذيه
ان للناس حرياتهم
وحرماتهم
وكراماتهم التي لا يجوز ان تنتهك في صوره
من الصور
ولا ان تمس بحال من الاحوال ايش يعني هذا
الكلام يعني الانسان
له ان يكون
منزويا عن انظار الناس هذا من اختيار
الناس وهذا حق اعطاه الله عز وجل لعباده
الا يكون مطلعا عليك الا الله هذا من حقك
يقول ففي المجتمع الاسلامي الرفيع الكريم
يعيش الناس امنين على انفسهم امنين على
بيوتهم امنين على اسرارهم امنين على
عوراتهم
ولا يوجد مبرر مهما يكن لانتهاك حرمات
الانفس والبيوت والاسرار والعورات
حتى ذريعه
تتبع تتبع الجريمه وتحقيقها لا تصلح في
النظام الاسلامي ذريعه للتجسس على الناس
هذا كلام يعني في غايه الخطوره
يقول حتى ذريعه تتبع الجريمه
وتحقيق وتحقيقها لا تصلح في النظام
الاسلامي ذريعه للتجسس على الناس فالناس
على ظواهرهم
وليس لاحد ان يتعقب بواطنهم وليس لاحد ان
ياخذهم الا بما يظهر منهم من مخالفات
وجرائم
الحكومه ليس من شانها
ان تجبر الناس على طاعه الله وانما
لها ان تقوم الناس اذا من حرفوا ظاهرا في
المجتمع
هذا هذا
هذه هي عين الفائده من الوالي
الوالي الامر ولي الامر والحكومه
الاسلاميه هي تقوم
للحفاظ على اموال الناس واعراض الناس
ودماء الناس
واما عباده الله سبحانه وتعالى فيكون
بالظاهر واما الباطن فهذا الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ويقول الله عز وجل
لا اكراه في الدين قد تبين الرشد من الغيب
فالذي يكون في المجتمع المسلم ويكون تحت
الولايه الاسلاميه الشرعيه
فان فانه يقوم بالنظام الشرعي ظاهرا وفي
المجتمع وليس له ان يفسد ولكن قد يفسد
وقد يفسد هو في في خلوته لكن ليس له ان
يفسد غيره ولا ان يظهر الفساد في الناس
هذا ليس له وهنا تكون اقامه الحدود نحن
نامر الناس بالتقوى
وقل لهم في انفسهم قولا بليغا
فنحن
نبلغ الرساله ونخوف الناس ونسمعهم
قول الله سبحانه وتعالى
ولكن
الهدايه بيد الله انك لا تهدي من احببت
والحكومه الاسلاميه ليس لها ان تدخل في
بيوت الناس
ليس لها ذلك وانما لها في الظاهر
وانما لها تقويم المجتمع
والحفاظ على الجل الغفير من المجتمع وان
يحفظ المجتمع من المفسدين
يقول وليس لاحد ان يظن او يتوقع او حتى
يعرف انهم يزاولون في الخفائن مخالفه ما
فيتجسس عليهم ليضبطهم
وكل ما له عليهم ان ياخذهم بالجريمه عند
وقوعها وانكشافها مع الضمانات الاخرى التي
ينص عليها بالنسبه لكل جريمه
ثم ساق حديثا لابي داود عن ابن مسعود
انه قيل له هذا فلان تقطر لحيته خمرا
فقال عبد الله
انا قد نهينا عن التجسس ولكن ان يظهر لنا
شيء ناخذ به
وهذا حديث حسن وعن مجاهد لا تجسسوا خذوا
بما ظهر لكم ودعوا ما ستر الله
ودعوا ما ستر الله هل كل واحد منا يحتاج
ستر الله هل في منه احد لا يحتاج الى ستر
الله لسلامه باطنه ليس منا احد ليس منا
احد الا نبي يكون نبي من الانبياء
ليس منا احد وهو في حاجه ما الى ستر الله
فما الذي يدفع المؤمن ليكشف ستر الله عن
عبد الله عن غيره لذلك
يقولون العرب يقولون كما تدين تدان يعني
كما تعمل تجازى
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في صحيح الامام
مسلم يقول
ومن ستر مسلما ستره الله في الدنيا
والاخره هل منا احد ليس في حاجه ماسه الى
هذا الستر الى هذا الستر ما منا احد ما
منا بريء
ولذلك
فان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
من ستر عوره مؤمن فكانما استحيا موعوده من
قبرها وهذه روايه ضعيفه ولكن فيها ترغيب
فيها ترغيب للستر على المسلمين
يقول فهكذا اخذ النص طريقه في النظام
العملي للمجتمع الاسلامي ولم يعد مجرد
تهذيب للضمير وتنظيف للقلب بل صار سياجا
حول حرمات الناس وحقوقهم
وحرياتهم فلا تمس من قريب او بعيد
تحت اي ذريعه او ستار يعني ما في تعليل او
مبرر يبرر هذا التجسس وانتهاك حرمات الناس
فاين هذا المدى البعيد واين هذا الافق
السامق واين ما يتعاجب به اشد الامم
ديمقراطيه وحريه وحفظ لحقوق الانسان بعد
1400 عام
ثم
يعني شرع في الكلام على الغيبه جاء في
جامعه الترمذي
باسناد صحيح عن عبد الله بن عمر رضي الله
عنهما
قال
صعد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم على اعواد
منبره فقال ونادى بصوت رفيع حتى اسمع
حتى اسمع النساء في الخدور خارج المسجد
اللي كانت في بيتها سمعت صوت النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم من علو صوته وهو ينادي
بالتالي قال يا معشره من امن بلسانه
ولما يدخل الايمان في قلبه لا تؤذوا
المؤمنين ولا تتبعوا عوراتهم فمن تتبع
عوره اخيه المسلم تتبع الله عورته
ومن تتبع الله عورته
يفضح ولو في جوف بيته
هذا كلام الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
ويخبرنا عن هذا الاسلوب هذا الاسلوب يدل
على ان هذه شيمه المنافقين اليس كذلك يعني
يا معشر من امن بلسانه
ولما يفضي الايمان الى قلبه هذه صفه من
صفه المنافقين ويناديهم يقول لا تؤذوا
المؤمنين لا تؤذوا المسلمين ولا تتبعوا
عوراتهم فمن تتبع عوره اخيه المسلم تتبع
الله عورته ومن تتبع الله عورته يفضحه ولو
في جوف رحله
وياتي السؤال عن بعض الاحوال التي ينبغي
ان نفهمها على وجهها فمثلا ياتي والد مثلا
يقول انا اولادي عندهم مثلا هواتف
وانا بدي اراقبهم شو بسوي
واحجزهم عن الشر
وانا اصلا مش بتبع عوراتهم انا اصلا ايش
بمنعهم عن الشر اقول نعم لك ان تحط برنامج
في التلفون
بتشوف اللي بشوفه وتسمع اللي بسمعه ولكن
تخبره
اعرفه
واما قصه انه واحد وهذه كثره في ايامنا
كما ان الشر كثر
كيف
لان من السهل جدا انك ترسل رساله لاي واحد
انا طبعا مش تبع كمبيوترات لكن تسمع الناس
يفعلون تنزل مثلا
تسمع انه واحد مثلا بودي لك رساله مجرد
انك تفتح الرساله وتدخل برنامج على
التلفون عندك بصير كل اشي يعكس عنده على
التلفون كل اشي
ويصورك ويسمع لك ويصور اللي حواليك ويسمع
اللي حواليك واي اشي بتطقه جوا الهذا ببين
عنده اي مكان بتروح عليه هذا من اكبر
الفساد
هذا من اكبر المنكر ومهما يدخل فيه هذا
صاحب الجوال فالذي تجسس عليه فكبرته اكبر
بكثير
وجاء عن عبد الله بن عباس عند الامام
البخاري ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
من استمع الى حديث قوم وهم له
منكرون او وهم له كارهون يصب في اذنيه
الانوك يوم القيامه ايش الانوك الانوك
يعني الرصاص المذاب المغلي
يصب في اذني الذي يستمع الى حديث قوم وهم
له كارهون
هذا لا يجوز
المسلم ينظر الى عورات
العدو في الحرب ليس الى اخوانه المسلمين
مهما كانت تبرير ما في تبرير
كذلك قد يسال السائل هل يجوز مثلا صاحب
العمل صاحب العمل يركب مثلا كمرات في
المحل شوف العمال شو بيسووا نقول يجوز لكن
يكون ظاهر
يكون شيء ظاهر صح ولا لا يعني الكاميرا
وهي جماعه هذه الكاميرا مع انه هذا رغب
عنه العلماء
يعني الان مثلا
اذا انا
بشغلك عندي تشغل عندي في المحل بس يا عمي
بحط لك كاميرا في وجهك وين ما تلف وجهك
ماشي
في
كل مكان في كاميرا بتبحر عليك
هل هذا جائز اذا انت دخلت في العمل
واعلمت كذلك ووافقت على العمل هل هو جائز
جائز المؤمنون على شروطهم نفس الشيء لو
يكون لك انا يا عمي بدي اوقف معك طول
النهار المعلم انت يا عمي اذا بدك واحد
يبقى موقف على راسك هيك وراضي بتشتغل انت
ونصيبك
لكن تخبره
لكن هل هذا من المروءه مثلا يعني عندك
عمالك اخوانك المسلمين
بتحط كاميرات في وجههم وين
كالحشره تحت الزجاجه يعني وهيني انا بتفرج
يعني ليس من المروءه لكن هذا لا يدخل في
باب التجسس التجسس يكون
مع عدم رضا
وعدم علم المتجسس عليه هذا اسمه تجسس مهما
يكون حتى المراه حتى الابن حتى مين يكون
واذا كان الانسان يشك في ولده يشك في زوجه
يشك في كذا يصارح
يصارح
بس عنا شيء بوسوس
يمسكه بدك تمسكها ابصر شو بتسوي ابصر مع
مين بتحكي ابصر ابصر ابصر
لا يا عمي انت يا اخوي بدك تحل المشكله صح
ولا لا اذا حل المشكله يكون بالمصارحه
بالنظر في العقوبات الشرعيه فيما شابه ذلك
والاتفاق
ومعالجه الامور هكذا واما التجسس فاذا دخل
هذا التجسس على المسلمين افسدهم
افسدهم
ويخشى على من فعل ذلك مهما كان تبريره
يخشى عليه ان يكون ممن تتبع الله عوراتها
فاذا كان ممن تتبع الله عوراتهم فسد يعني
هلك لا محاله
هذا ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى التوفيق
والمغفره وان يوفقنا
للعمل والقول الصحيح وان يجعلني واياكم
ممن يستمعون القول فيتبعون احسانا
نعلن ختاما عن وفاه الاخ شادي
قبلاوي من نابلس فلسطين العزاء مستمر في
الاقصى الى التاسعه غفر الله لنا ولا هو
ولموت المسلمين صلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين